et j'ai cherché un échappe à une
échappatoire alors que je sortais j'ai
entendu dire d'une voix en colère tu
m'as bien excité petite [ __ ]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hammerson sa chaîne youtube sur sa
chaîne youtube elle fait la même chose
karine alors karine elle a fait ça et à
pompe et karine et
je pense qu'elle a pompé d'autres
personnes n'est pas moi c'est parce que
je voulais dire
alors bon c'est vrai que ça
tu peux deviner qu'un garçon il dit ça
ça aurait provoqué un scandale sur les
réseaux grass et une double attaque
d'abord c'est parce qu'elles pensent que
magali parce que à la une image un peu
superficielle capable de s'exprimer ces
gens qui pensent que les milieux
autorisés s'autorise à penser c'est
absolument scandaleux c'est du mépris ça
me choque profondément et c'est vrai que
de dire à une femme à la pompe et
excusez moi c'est une violence extrême
c'est que c'est quoi selon les échos mag
et berlin elle a aussi pourquoi pascal
et à la pompe et des mecs mais dans
quelle banque et dans quelle vie on peut
sourire une chose pareille je trouve ça
scandaleux c'est pas drôle c'est
humiliant c'est rabaissant c'est un vrai
scandale ils ont commencé par dire oui
elle fait pitié failli sauter
particulièrement violent et mes chances
que ça c'est vraiment que la fin d'une
interview fin de la rigolade là et puis
je trouvais sympa drôle et puis je suis
maman j'ai trois enfants je vais dire
c'est pas pourquoi enfin j'veux dire
s'il faut respecter moi mes filles elles
vivent le cyber harcèlement ça fait cinq
ans que je fais ce métier sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est un métier qui est
très violent que j'ai subies j'accepte
aussi mais il ya du ne venant d'une
femme comme ça surtout quand elle est
mal placé parce que quand elle a eu des
problèmes ou quand elle s'est sentie
attaque elle pour rien par exemple à
lyon pas mais kelly où elle s'est sentie
attaqué pour rien puisque c'était mignon
puisqu'éric moi j'ai regardé la vidéo
l'autre jour geste est mignon lcl
l'anafé tout un roman sur les réseaux
sociaux fait des années que nous faire
un roman là dessus et ça on aurait dit
ça d'elle ici avec tout le bordel qu'à
la
boutique à non mais c'est sûr à nous
sourire au delà de la pseudo vannes qui
était vasco fifa c'est quand même
profondément méprisant et les très mal
placé pour ça puisque elle même a été
jugé quand elle recevait des politiques
parce que c'était une animatrice qui
étaient reçus du divertissement donc au
lieu de faire ça elle devrait encourager
magali barda le faire plutôt que la
critique et oui c'est ridicule et en
plein air on se moquer d'elle pour sa
part connu pas moi je suis avec
attention je suis désolé mais je ne suis
pas une coureuse de faim je sais pas
comment on appelle ça de garçons que je
qui a été mariée pendant 15 ans
je trouve qu'on commence au fur et à
mesure à voir enfin le vrai visage de
karine le marchand moi ça me fait
plaisir parce qu'on entend beaucoup de
trucs en off mais leur moelleux montre
d'elle même à la télé donc je trouve ça
plutôt 7 en même temps moi je trouve que
c'est un peu une guéguerre de
2-2-2 d'un montant de la loose i de frei
n'a pas 40 ans ocarina oui elle est plus
vieille oui à la 55 ans accepte
de nouvelles informations sont parues
dans le magazine public révélant que
l'animateur serait directement liée à la
fameuse affaire du carlton de lille est
donc à dominique strauss kahn des deux
hommes ne seraient donc pas vu que sur
l'état tout est déjà vendu en fait à
faire à des documents juridiques de la
sphère 4 carlton affaire pour laquelle
dominique strauss-kahn était mis en
examen pour proxénétisme aggravé en
bande organisée
à l'époque il a été relaxé et dans ces
documents
une jeune femme qui était stagiaire en
2007 chez rmc raconte qu'elle a été mise
en contact avec dominique strauss kahn
par l'entremise de jean jacques bourdin
alors je me connais si bien dominique
strauss kahn alors jean jacques bourdin
le connaissait bien sa femme il l'a dit
lui même était était très ami avec avec
le connais depuis combien de temps
depuis plusieurs années sa femme me
connais je peux pas vous dire que j'ai
une dizaine d'années oui plus d'une
dizaine seraient justement 2014
le journaliste jean jacques bourdin
était sur notre plateau de tpm pays
est-ce que vous avez anniversaire de
dominique strauss kahn c'est vrai ça
fait vingt-cinq minutes pendant cinq
minutes ben je m'en vais expliquer
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
ma femme est très ami avec dominique
strauss kahn d'accord
en fait jean jacques bourdin recevait
dominique strauss-kahn et il n'y aurait
selon ses propos présentés dominique
strauss kahn qui lui aurait donné
ensuite rendez-vous dans sa voiture
après l'émission voiture garée sur le
trottoir à quelques pas de la station et
que au lieu de parler carrière ce qu
elle l espérer faire avancer sa carrière
sa carrière je vois la réaction de
géraldine à l'extérieur faire monter sa
carrière en fait vous aurez eu une
relation sexuelle et ce qu'elle explique
dans ce témoignage n'est qu'ensuite elle
a été prise dans un engrenage qu'elle
aurait été sous l'emprise de dominique
strauss kahn et qu'elle aurait
effectivement participé à des soirées où
se déroulait d où se seraient déroulées
pardon je suis obligé d'utiliser le
conditionnel des orgies sexuelles
il ya aujourd'hui rebondissement dans la
sphère jean jacques bourdin deux
plaintes contre jean-jacques bourdin
fanny agostini et cette nouvelle femme
âgée de 61 ans les faits sont prescrits
il ya eu plusieurs métiers témoignages
un témoignage aussi le niveau n'est que
dans mediapart témoignage d'une ancienne
stagiaire de rmc dans médiapart de
témoignages de femmes qui travaillent
dans les médias elle porte plainte pour
agression sexuelle harcèlement et
exhibitions puisqu'elle raconte en fait
que lorsqu'elle a rencontré jean jacques
bourdin pour la première fois en 1988 il
a d'abord je veux dire ce qu'elle à dire
puisque un jour donc les aviez faire un
journal bourdin lui propose de visiter
les locaux de rtl où il travaille cette
jeune femme accepte elle dit j'étais
timide et impressionné car je savais
qu'ils étaient connus il s'est garé dans
une petite rue une petite rue à côté
d'rtl il m'a regardé d'une façon très
intense et tout s'est déroulé rapidement
il a ouvert la braguette de son pantalon
et a fait apparaître son sexe en
érection il était comme entrer en transe
il avait comme un nouveau visage une
double face il m'a dit je sais que toi
aussi tu en as envie myriam vous saviez
qu'il y avait cette plainte qu'elle est
sortie
il ya quelques jours effectivement le
savait elle je ne la connais pas on ne
connaissent pas parce que c'est que vous
avez vous connaissez très bien mais dans
leur foi voilà après je me suis
renseigné parce qu'au début quand j'ai
entendu parler de standards dit je
savais que c'était une sorte d'armé je
croyais que c'était celle de la deûle
affaire dsk mais pas du tout là c'est
une standardiste beaucoup de plus âgés
et ce qui est assez choquant enfin c'est
déjà la façon dont ils l'auraient
abordée dès le départ dès le départ la
femme qui a donc 28 ans à l'époque se
retrouvent tétanisés jean jacques
bourdin lui aurait proposé de la payer
il m'a dit qu'il a adoré faire ça en
payant il m'a demandé de jouer la [ __ ]
la [ __ ] il a sorti un carnet de
chèques l'ont recouvert de cuir noir il
m'a demandé combien je voulais il a dit
2000 francs et a rempli le chèque elle
raconte ensuite je me rappelle l'anc re
bleu et d'une écriture en pattes de
mouche il tremblait et m'a dit que si
j'étais gentil avec lui et que si je
faisais ce qu'il voulait il en aurait
d'autres de chèques jean jacques bourdin
lui aurait posé le chèque sur ses genoux
et aurait tenté de l'embrasser de force
il l'a fait je cite de façon assez
brutale en rapprochant son corps contre
le mien et on me coince en contre la
portière j'étais acculé j'ai tenté de le
repousser il attrapé ma main gauche avec
sa main droite et l'a dirigé vers son
sexe toujours en érection vas-y je sais
que tu en meurent d'envié elle ajoute je
ne sais pas si j'ai touché son sexe ou
si je les ai juste effleuré j'ai été
apeurés et j'ai cherché un échappé d'une
échappatoire alors que je sortais j'ai
entendu dire d'une voix en colère tu
m'as bien excité petite [ __ ]
les faits sont avérés c'est extrêmement
violent la plaignante ensuite se serait
cassé le talon en sortant de la voiture
elle ne dira rien par peur d'être viré
par son directeur le parisien raconte
également qu'elle ne dira rien lorsque
le journaliste est revenu dans les
locaux après les rendez-vous il passait
par les toilettes qui est en face du
standard il conseille la porte avec son
pied et se masturber en meringue en me
regardant ce incroyable je faisait mine
de ne pas le voir alors ça c'est ça
commence à devenir vraiment très très
compliqué d'autant plus que ce
témoignage il est particulièrement
l'a beaucoup dit
sonne vrai les salles juste et donc pour
son envie malheureusement la scène quand
on lit le témoignage de cette femme elle
a donc décidé de porter plainte hier
après midi car elles voient je cite une
dichotomie entre l'homme public et
l'homme dans la vie
on continue avec quelques nouvelles de
l'ohada la star de téléréalité a surpris
tout le monde aujourd'hui en proposant à
sa communauté des messages vidéo
dédicaces et qu'elle facturait quelle
facture et le paf acte facturait rebuter
pour casser les jeunes élèves c'est le
site vidéo les eaux et je crois qu'il ya
benjamin dont pas celui-là mais sur un
autre là d'accord il ya gilles verdez
alors ouais
bon voilà je voulais vous annoncer que
si vous voulez un petit message pour
toutes occasions vous pouvez contacter
me contactez moi surtout pour que je
puisse vous souhaitez ce que vous voulez
quand vous voulez vous voulez voilà vous
ferez de gros bisous voile alors loana
c'est 60 euros la loi de le faire mais
voilà après il ya des femmes qui sont
énervés parce qu elle monnaye des
dédicaces après un moment il faut
essayer de gagner sa croûte
le boulanger
et gâchis le vrd également gilbert d'al
sadd a trouvé le profil de gilles verdez
40 euros pour une vidéo 30 euros 46
40 euros il ya castaldi 6,50 euros hum
voilà qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
dans le cadre manhattan tout ça c'est
plutôt bien elle a besoin d'argent c'est
compliqué à dire dans le cas de benjamin
c'est un ami je fais pas un départ
non après voilà moi l'histoire par
exemple gens qui font des booking en
boîte de nuit ton métier c'est d'animer
tient que de cotinine dans une boîte de
nuit dans un grand magasin ou à la télé
tu fais ton métier mais quelque part
euros dit dire à dire quelque chose de
gentil à quelqu'un bonne anniversaire
c'est comme si dans la rue othman un
autographe automne hiver est ce que tu
peux faire une dédicace est un ami et
faisait payer comme ça c'est plutôt
métier ton métier c'est pas d'être
connue tomber tcdd et animateur donc toi
quand tu fais ça tu pars du principe que
ton métier ses débuts connu gilles est
quand même plus loin des grandes leçons
à tout le monde surtout et a pas besoin
d'argent il me semble hélas tous les
soirs donc finalement tu fais payer le
fait que tu es célèbre ta célébrité
c'est un métier gilles mais douchez je
le dis agile et je le dis aussi à
benjamin même si c'est mon ami contre
moi je le dis aussi à benjamin c'est
choquant loana je suis comme mathieu que
loana sans galères et qu'elle arrive les
gens ils lui donnent 60 euros mois comme
c'est ok d'accord ok mais les deux là
ils n'ont pas besoin de 50 euros ou de
40 au juste donc tu vas sur instagram
combien deux années à temps et je
[Musique]
sais très bien les faits vous allez sur
instagram vous demandez des messages aux
gens ils vont voulait faire moi y'a des
gens qui me demandent des vidéos sur un
stade comme j'ai que ça à [ __ ] fait
des vidéos sur un stage en voix aux gens
je demande pas 50 bâches demande pas de
60 balles et je vais même te dire je ne
demanderai jamais parce que ces gens à
qui vous demande ça c'est des gens qui
vous aiment énormément pour aller
donnant 60 balader avec comme vous faut
vraiment vous aimez vous les uns elle
même du beau jason pas en plus
tiens aussi des petits montants comme ça
mais quand c'est une entreprise par
exemple une entreprise qui le demande
pour fêter voilà c'est jusqu'à 1000 1500
euros les gros à noël ils battent pour
un booking que tu prends et je sais mon
métier des limites pardon mon métier
c'est pas des scellés
[Musique]
pépé paul un à noël pour 195 ont voté un
hameau ban à noël pendant les fêtes les
animateurs se font jusqu'à 10000 euros
par mois dix mille euros par mois pour
vendre uniquement quoi lors célébrités
d'argentine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
but de kane je vous raconterai une
petite anecdote après sur rien
[Musique]
je
ap pas de position de hors jeu à la
faute dans la surface pour ce cas la
personne ya débat
derrière audi
[Applaudissements]
ouais quillanais mbappé et c'est vrai
que c'est ça héros moi je l'adoré je
vous raconter une anecdote parce que
qu'il gagne il n'a pas du tout la grosse
tête il m'est arrivé de faire des
soirées voilà avec les joueurs de
l'équipe de france qu'ils avaient un
truc a fait des et c'est vrai que
j'avais un truc a fini comme tout le
monde et c'est vrai que qu'il y avait un
truc à fêter vous avez des ânes
organisation je vais vous dire la vérité
et c'est vrai que kilian je l'aï vu dans
la soirée c'est lui qui organise et
c'est pousser les tables ils doivent
demander à quelle si on voulait boire
quelque chose c'est un mec qui se prend
pas du tout la tête et moi y'a un truc
qui m'a marqué il m'a dit maniant il m'a
dit ouais c'est moi qui ai demandé au
coach si on pouvait sortir ce soir et
s'ils m'avaient thinon serait pas sorti
mais bon il m'a dit d'accord allez tu
peux y aller ce soir et tout franchement
c'est un garçon mais je vous jure une
humilité une gentillesse je les adore
voilà et il mérite et il est tellement
dans son truc ça veut dire que quand
vous lui parlez il peut vous parler tout
mais il est dans son match il est dans
sa vie il est c'est voilà c'est sa
passion et c'est un vrai passionné c'est
un vrai bosseur il bosse à fond je veux
dire il est là tous les jours à
l'entraînement à l'heure il déconne pas
laissez pas le beau et c'est pas la star
c'est un truc de fou donc voilà je pense
que c'est mérité qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui pour moi le meilleur joueur
du monde je pense voilà oui je vais
raconter une petite anecdote sur sa
générosité si vous le permettez parce
que un jour il a fait la couverture de
time magazine qui est célèbre dans le
monde entier et sa maman a eu l'idée en
voyant ce en lui disant mais c'est vrai
que tu as une dimension planétaire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on créerait pas une
association dont il a créé une
association inspired by k ml qu'il y
avait ma paie et il ya quatre-vingt
dix-huit enfants 98 comme son année de
naissance et comme l'année de la paix sa
victoire en coupe du monde de bondy et
d'ailleurs qui bénéficient d'un
encadrement complet soutien scolaire
cours particuliers séjour au ski
week-end avec l'inde d'un groupe
hôtelier sponsor du psg je vais pas
donner le nom des locaux et voilà 98
enfant qui va accompagner de 12 à 20 ans
pour qu'ils grandissent qui mûrissent
qui réalisent leur rêve c'est beau quand
même pas une star comme les franchement
c'est la sacem maps et gmail
[Applaudissements]
est
ce que toi quand tu étais miss quand on
voit là dans le travail est ce que tu as
déjà eu des débours d'eau qui tombent
chauffe équipements et t'envoyer des sms
ou qu'ils tombent oui oui oui en règle
général les maires ont des mains
baladeuses ça c'est vrai pendant les
maires du canton fait enfin les
politiques je vais chez vous pour faire
les photos à machin donc effectivement
c'est au niveau de passer au niveau là
et puis à la fin de la photo pour ça
descend et voilà donc maintenant je sais
comment faire dès que je sens qu'elle
descende qu'elle veut descendre et ben
et bien je la remets en place et je le
regarde et vois déjà c'est
incroyable on va refaire toutes les
villes que tu as fait ton album c'est
fou après sinon tu as déjà eu vraiment
généralement les les hommes qui ont
beaucoup de pouvoir les hommes très
riches j'ai déjà eu plusieurs demandes
en mariage non avec des des zones même
très très très vieux quand j'avais 20
ans un homme de 70 ans 75 je suis allé
manger avec lui et je sais pas
d'ailleurs ce que devient et il m'a dit
mais
c'est vrai que en fait
ben ça faisait pas longtemps que j'étais
sorti de miss france donc le chercher un
peu des plans pour travailler et tout il
a dit si tu vends pas aller déjeuner
ensemble il m'avait dit que je pouvais
être un peu égérie de sa marque
d'ailleurs je mets plus que c'était
comme marc et après au bout d'un moment
il me dit alors et est ce que tu es en
couple et tu sais moi je suis
célibataire si tu veux on pourrait faire
un peu échange de bons procédés
et en gros c'était de l'argent contre
centre être à ses côtés il a dit moi je
suis seul et puis toi tu as envie d'un
coup de pouce je peux te le donner
on n'a pas très bon coup de pouce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]